oh
good my god my huge big muscles are so
sore
my big giant enormous muscles are so
sore alex alex really slapping you
around these days oh you know how it'd
be
uh so what's the deal with this game
there's rooms they kill us yeah
something like that it's like the cube
we've played it before for anyone at
home um who's gonna set up this thing
what size room we want to start off with
the defaults three by three by three uh
let's just do default at first let's not
go crazy
the default difficulties i'm too young
to die
then there's hey not too rough hurt me
plenty this is the violence nice [ __ ]
cold stone creamery of video games
what's happening now yeah that's classic
doom like the original doom difficulty
levels lots of difficulty options here
so which one you want what do you hurt
me plenty
dude hurt me a lot hurt me so much all
right sending you an invite
oh are you now
trying to invite mark is always a
nightmare on this but i managed oh my
god
wow what an absolute nightmare you are
mark you're a nightmare mark what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] you guys what the [ __ ]
oh
i turned my mouse sensitivity down a
little bit low it turns out sensitivity
of one is good for the menus bad for the
game do you think this is a trap
uh no it's definitely there we go
are we all three
sarah sterling oh oops no no i'm the i'm
ash you're ashley i'm sarah we're sarah
we we are sarah you're the other girl
you're the other girl we are sarah
great
love that would you guys like some
orange
oops
[Music]
oh god oh god whoa what the hell
i see you're talking about bob if you
hit w it takes like a full second before
you start moving yeah that's like a
that's like input delay or something
right yeah
i don't know
how who who grabbed food how did you do
that
half oh dude
watching us just watched us put down
this entire table of food like snakes
eating an egg
[Music]
this feels like it was important for
healing or something but who cares no no
no
no let's go
oh
what is that i don't want to go in there
i feel like it's just black
okay that's probably fine
[Laughter]
oh man your health's really going down
yeah oh my god is there some food wait
hold you hold your breath
hold your breath
[Music]
oh shoot
well that's a damn shame oh is it like
minesweeper you see on the minimap it
says one and one so there's one
i see yeah so
that's probably safe over here yeah
definitely
confident about that and this is a safe
this is a zero
that's unfortunate wayne yeah we'll get
you back don't worry wait a minute oh
look there's that room
in me hmm we can see can't we like find
you remember
your teammates will save you i don't
know what that means why do i have less
health what happened why do i do we eat
too much
are we dying of
food
is food slowly poisoning us
well i also called you wade sorry booty
just gonna let that door close that
would look moderately survivable though
oh hey i found wade hey what
uh how's it going bud hey i'm good hey
welcome
is this the exit yeah
i think there's food down there
what i think this is floor one of three
wow now we're on floor two of three hey
this says there's three dangerous rooms
and there's only three openable doors oh
we did the smallest map
let's just stay oh that's oh
no
that's fine oh
oh wow you're right there are three
dangerous rooms that's that's pretty fun
we can't go that way
what are we doing i'll go this room you
go that room i'll go there you go
i'll go this way this team's fine
in that room
oh i found acid rain
it feels bad this feels bad
holy [ __ ]
oh my god i feel safe
oh man
it's fire time in here hey guys
uh
there's no way out of here i think
that's what i think okay oh no no it's
fun yeah yeah there you go that looks
good there's two to one there's this is
how this has to be safe this has to be
right
why did mark disconnect oh no i'm here
i'm here hey oh hey what's up yeah he's
alive i'm still dead though this time it
seems fine yeah totally fine uh well
this is not my game i have found
hey you're not maybe you'll be in this
thing
[Laughter]
wait are you are you here are you in the
room with us no he did i'm dead but i'm
spectating you no that means this is
safe right yeah
oh you go first
i don't know the lava pistol
yeah
well there's two doors and two dangerous
rooms attached so let's just see what's
behind door number whoa hey tetris
i mean rubik's cube what's behind door
number two
sand hmm
[Music]
well that's not too deadly
yeah that's not too dare i'll take my
chances with mr cube over here
oh you know what i'm going to just go
with mark then that's fine
careful
oh hey
oh
[Music]
you good bro oh i win
oh i
gave it over
well do i win oh yeah i win i found um
i found three rooms two of which killed
you i think i scored it twenty thousand
dude i only scored 10 000. holy hell i'm
at 11 000. how the hell am i 11. because
i'm so good at that i just do [ __ ] i won
how am i have the lowest score all right
let's get a bigger amount
bigger map
four by four by four okay cool that's
good what's happening to get out of the
dead
wait wait what what dude it said to get
out of a deadly room you need to break
two flasks i don't know what that meant
i didn't read the rest of it there was
something there
mine said that in order to heal yourself
eat the food in the main yeah uh-huh we
know
whatever
dude have some have some food wait what
are you doing oh i will
right okay all through this safe room
all the rooms are safe over here nice
safe room perfectly all the rooms are
safe i guess we're all going our own way
you're safe or not it's zero it's like
mine sweeper
there's a boot over here
oh hey mr krabs
um
well that's not deadly
i don't know what they have on them are
those explosives
i don't like the area
i don't know if these are good things to
touch don't
this one's a maze mark you want to come
in the maze no that's where the snail
was fire
hey what's up
yeah i'm on fire a little bit
the exit oh the exit all
oh hey i guess he's your friend forever
he doesn't want to go in the hole
oh
oh wait but that's where we're going no
it's fine it's fixed foreign
yeah that's our friend we want to get to
the end of the game
he's not me big huskies you sure do oh
that seems bad
oh that means this one must be safe
right that's what i'm doing
okay
geez oh he's jumped mark the door's
gonna close lose him watch him
lose him lose him lose it oh god damn it
you look food hey food numb no no no no
no no no
do you guys want to try to trick him
into that other room really quick take
him back down oh there's a barrel it's
exploding
yeah watch out for the snail bite
that's a gun that's a gun
yeah snail
oh mark mark got him stuck on the door
oh god the barrel still happening
guys watch out for the gun oh he walks
over the table that's not very cool it's
fine everything's fine mark where are
you going buddy
i'm going this way
oh that's going to be fun hey close
close
i lost them
oh wait
found the exit
um okay and got it
hey what's up and i lost our friend hey
oh
oh i can't i fell in the [ __ ] i fell in
the hole
all right fair enough
oh no i fell in the holy
bad room is connected to this one no
okay i'll try this one
well they can't all be oh no they cannot
deal
oh yeah don't mess with the snail he's
bad dude i thought you were lying
i thought i was lying
he's just like watch out for this okay
mark the snail okay i'm just telling you
man
well it's probably safe otherwise
yeah
oh god oh god oh god
oh mark what a room you found over here
well i know some stuff about the other
oh
there's a gun in this one as well oh man
uh i'm gonna just
come
[Music]
did you wait which way did you go i
don't know i i had to run i had to make
a lot of running
but uh i found the exit not
a lot of choice in the matter
holy [ __ ] um this is the end of me
uh guys that's just a water room ow
guys this might be the end of me oh no
oh god okay i made it i made it i made
it i made it i made it hey look at the
end hey lulu oh my god you have someone
behind you i know
what are you doing behind you
i know it's a problem we're perfectly
fine here landmines
we're good it's fine let's wait get over
it okay well this room is not scary yeah
come on
yeah i'm gonna try and experiment [ __ ]
yeah it's fine
[Laughter]
let's just open all the doors and see
what happens just kill him well time to
find out we're going in baby
the fire
[Laughter]
all right i'm going for it i'm going for
it i'm going for it
you have a mood
oh my god i invade health oh [ __ ] oh the
dragon oh mark
oh mark you're not finding good things
no oh no
i'm going for it i have four health i
have four health that's not enough oh
if i had just randomly gone the other
way i could have got there i know got
decapitated in a room full of crabs
happens to the best in this man nowhere
to go but five by five by five five by
five turn it up to nightmare
you want nightmare done okay uh we can
go to 10 by 10 by 10. then there's
pyramid oh no
pyramid times eight i'm okay
because i imagine that's like
three then four then five which would
actually let's do the pyramid i think
that's a more interesting way to do it
let's do a pyramid times two up to times
eight do pyramid five pyramid five would
that end on a five by five or would that
end on like a eight by eight ah let's
find out we'll find out
worth
you guys see that what is that
i'm curious but i'm not curious enough
to step on it with my own feet what if i
do that
oh
well that's not so bad okay well yeah
that's the give me my boot back i'll
take my boot back wait give me my shoe
back oh i did get my boot back okay well
oh you didn't on my screen ah it's all
right i got it on my screen oh wait
there's there's oh that's fine
oh green
hey what's going on good
oh hey there's another snapper
that's fine
i lost some health i'm gonna go eat some
food did you get snapped i may have not
noticed the other snapper i drank some
milk cut my thighs and my shoes
exit exit exit everybody
oh i seem to be good at finding these
exits don't go why would you go that way
no
oh you'll find the flag
flasks
i flasked it oh we need two shoes on the
same door that's what the flasks are
guys i flasked my way out i could have
survived
yeah you really could you could yeah you
could you absolutely could have gone out
of here
but it costs your shoe like the shoe
dies interesting yeah my shoes is gone
now i got no shoes that's okay
but i flashed my way to freedom
hmm
[Applause]
wow all right we're out of shoes well
wade will save us there
oh
i just let that shoe go i think um well
that that's that means this one's safe
and this one won't be that bad either
[ __ ]
oh hey look how long that is oh it broke
it broke
dude it broke
what's happening it broke
oh neat is it because you threw your
shoe at it
maybe them shoes are powerful
this one says four so there's no way
that this one itself is bad right
no wait um that's not true that's not
true
that's not true i'll find out
oh no that's not good hey wait i don't
know
you can break me out with hey i could i
could punch the flask if i wanted to but
it's all right guys just break me out
with your shoes oh yeah oh okay yeah
it's really getting kind of chilly in
here something is happening to my body
oh hey your life with zero help oh never
mind
it's cold i was right the first time
okay well
this way it is
dragon room it is oh hey buddy okay
that's a lot of fours i don't like the
fours i know that's a lot of forces
there's a lot of fours all right i'm
gonna
oh i don't like that i'm going in
i'm going in with the crow oh wait
hey mark what what's up okay i'm going
to do this with the right call oh
god
crabs
you got this bob i'm not actually taking
any damage do we're seemingly fine
i'm just trapped in here forever
oh but mark will find some shoes and get
you out yeah mark could you find two
shoes and then save me i have one shoe
that i found
that almost is enough for the way to say
oh bart there's another shoe in the
corner
oh where
that corner uh that you're facing the
left
left oh there it is hanging up in the
corner yeah i see it wow there's can you
save me
i can technically i suppose
will you save me
for fire right now i will i will save
you this snowman oh hey what's up buddy
okay got it come with me
okay
oh the dragon is here
yeah
that exact moment was not advisable
it's five to five to five to five to
five what is with this pissing dragon
i don't want to go in there that doesn't
seem very oh i gotta risk it i gotta
risk it
it's fine this must be it how is this
not the exit
oh god uh
there's one yeah how's that going mark i
know i know i know i know i know i know
i know is that the exit the one room it
is definitely the exit it is the exit
oh we could have gotten there in like
two two rooms yeah we could have gotten
right there you know what i'm just going
to go the other way i didn't notice the
spiky chain ball yeah look it's got a
flask on it you can you can break all of
it yeah so you can actually do a lot
with shoes i forgot there's a thing in
here oh don't come in don't come in no
come in
oh my god oh hey what's up guys why are
we all doing that what are we doing i
was debating on freeing my corpse from
it's frozen
you need two shoes
he has two shoes oh nevermind then how
do you get two shoes because he died
came back with shoes from death you come
back with both shoes that's silly
what
whoa
that revealed a lot in the area there's
a shoe in here what are the odds gonna
close if i walk in here not
too terrible probably all right wade i'm
gonna need one of your shoes if this
locks me in
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
no
hey guys how's it going hey what's up
man good worth it
that means this way has to be safe right
sure yeah oh yeah oh that looks safe
yeah it's safe man go for it go go go
you got it you got it go for it man go
for it see totally oh that's safe
you just gotta watch out for the steam
easy
easy doesn't that room have to be bad
it doesn't have to be bad i'm going for
it guys i'm gonna die to steam because i
suck
hey look guys
it's the exit
i have 36 38 health open the door over
there over there
hey
man how's it going
it's fine
yeah good job everybody that was good
all right four great
oh cool
whoa
what is that what the hell do you think
we should go into rock room i don't
think so that seems terrible all right
what about we're in a fort all the rooms
are bad
oh no
so many snails
why would you open another one
those are bad by the way the snail rooms
are safe now no no no they're not
there's definitely there's there's some
landmines or something okay so if this
is
[Music]
oh
my god you did hit a land mine with your
shoe
yeah i thought that's a really flaily
fire guy
still get
is dangerous
yeah go in there and see what happens
i'm sure it's fine
oh box of gloves that one still seems
like the least objectionable yeah
they're just boxing gloves what are they
gonna do hit but it's a three
yeah right ha ha ha
ha ha ha hey whoa whoa whoa wow
you can survive
um oh it's minotaur man
how do i spectate my oh hey friends i'm
in the [ __ ] me express
the what
oh hey you have a friend yeah i heard
you say that yeah oh my god those are
land mines in front of that door
all of these doors are dangerous every
one of these doors is dangerous
i will take the one with lasers laser
room yes
oh there's other stuff in laser room
that doesn't seem good
we got smart
mark
oh
nice snails
i have to go
oh my this one this one's definitely
dangerous you've got a three danger
uh-huh oh food
oh at least my ass survived
hey it was me
all right laser room i i don't trust
this other guy
no way man no way
oh god oh god
it's fine
oh hey
oh i'm alive whoa what happened hey
what's up buddy oh god you all got here
oh hey what's up dude hey we got a
friend coming in
god snail blow up the guide
okay what do we got here
okay that looks cold this is all crabs
how bad could a lip oh [ __ ] i like the
room with the two lasers in it i think
that's a good way to go it's good
let me back out
let me out
i'll mark it though if the friend is
with you mark just so you know oh god
okay i'm gonna just go oh
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't have any boots i don't have any
boots hang on uh uh
there's definitely a way to survive this
keep keep doing it keep living mark live
[Applause]
yeah here's the
plan great plan good plan
yep yep yep yep
yep
oh [ __ ] okay this is a good room this is
a good room check out the drawers see if
you can find the exit yep
yep yep i'm going deep boys
you're going deep
okay good good good oh oh oh oh oh i
don't like the laughter careful
i think i'm dead boys
well i didn't randomly find the exit by
sprinting full speed to my death no
oddly enough no that was rough killing
it guys no it's fine yeah i'm killing it
and dying it guys yeah
we're going back
go right back into it i like pyramid
good that's very cool and i'm glad you
liked it
hey
oh what the balls
it worked
oh these guys are fine oh balls get it
balls get it get it balls get it
[Music]
i killed the crab
i threw a building
oh
okay
hey guys there's an extra boot over here
uh-huh oh
bad that means this one's safe
yeah that's how it works this must be
the guys
i found a
cave oh we go up baby
i'm coming from watch out for your brain
wait we're going up go up yeah
oh [ __ ]
yo ow
god damn
oh god no no way it's death there's no
way it's fine right it's definitely fine
watch this watch oh hey crabs how are
you doing
crabs and flowers okay okay okay oh oh
god they're still
ah
okay the crabs are dead it's fine okay
we're fine
i don't know touch one probably i don't
think so i'm good
oh well this one's gonna have too
dangerous hey
well
i'm out of no i've got one shoe wait how
do i slow the shoe you have two shoes
eight i know but i killed the crab with
one i guess i got it back from the crib
um um um um i don't like how flaily this
fire is yeah
wait you're on fire i don't know if you
noticed
i did not it's fine
oh it's good oh oh the floor is coming
this way oh
you just ran through it like a
psychopath oh hey
oh darn it oh yeah there's a swingy
thing in here
yeah be careful guys you do it mark oh
that doesn't matter
it's fine man it's fine
oh god it's the other oh it's so far
away
oh my god that's not good
no shot dude
mark i think you're about to die hey
fire
you heal up a bit i know you do yeah you
healed back to 50 i think yeah you do
god that's a rock don't touch those
flowers if you
um if you're if you get curious i'm just
going to tell you don't do that don't
touch the flowers okay i was thinking
don't go that way that's not the way
what are you doing i can't go through
there what do you mean you're not going
to want to go you want to go um to the
and you're on fire again okay there's no
way there's a death room
sure
surrounded
[Applause]
by all right going up
[Music]
this one seems pretty safe
guys i found the safe one
you do it safe okay wow
open all three doors and find out that
we're safe free snails
why are they so terrified
ow he did one damage to me from across
the entire room uh
was this room safe
safe room bold of you to run inside of
it like that i threw my shoe first oh
okay crap
do i need to get mark's body or do we
just leave i think we just leave my
body's in many pieces uh so don't worry
about it it's fine i believe in you guys
oh no not that way
cool cool cool
i like that room that's a good room yeah
that's what'll be good that's gonna be
good
that's fine probably
i just this is zero it's a zero
it does say zero okay so that means we
know that okay we know the corner rooms
are good
oh hey oh [ __ ]
well let's just open this one and see
what surprises await us in here hey
buddy
okay well
i'm going in the zero room
okay
what
oh food room hey there's food over here
oh i could kind of use that
things on the ground there's many snappy
bites
i made it nice did you see that just saw
that wait why would you do that
are you kidding me no he was in there
what do you mean you didn't okay well i
didn't know he was still on bob you
deserve this where else would he go if
he's not on you there's two people
playing he's closed in now he's closed
in there okay well
we have a lot of room to explore
i feel like i need to go this way uh
i want to i want to try to get this way
oh [ __ ] all right
[Music]
how bad was this room this is just a
cube
[Music]
not just a cube
but i can oh okay golden brown
brush
oh
oh [ __ ]
that means this is also dangerous then
um fine
[ __ ]
no oh i broke the thing haha take that
we're going in here we're going in here
we're going in here
all right i got blown away but i'm i'm
blowing back we're going in here we're
going in here only one dangerous which
means the other door is perfectly fine
yep it's fine okay what's up oh my god
okay okay it's fine we're fine i'm fine
i'm in here now that's hardly fine
i feel safe are rocks bad mark ruck's
bad rocks are fine i don't know if the
room is fine but rocks are ow
i'll be careful all right
from a steam bird
yeah bob every single time i went to
wait it was calamity that's been my
entire playthrough that's why they call
him whoa
wade calamity barnes man i don't like
that my name we're going whoa you're
supposed to swing the other way okay i'm
on fire a little bit it's fine this is
fine
i'm going out
i'm coming
i was i was born up
hey what's up dudes i saved us this is
the last level we could make it we'll
just very careful how big the map is
though we'll just very carefully find
our way through
and snail it's always a snap
i thought you were joking
what if that was the double the hill
i uh uh wade go ahead no that's just a
cave it's totally safe probably yeah
totally safe it seems safe
i'll find out all right go for it
okay
i don't like the arms of the damn yeah
maybe duck yeah did you not see that
when we were telling you that that seems
safe okay
it used to be working actually i'm okay
all right i like that
and then a rock room i don't like the
noises if i'm 100 honestly yeah not my
favorite my shoe
oh okay
i'm gonna check over here interesting oh
it's false wait wait wait wait wait wait
let me out which one are you in
is this you
oh are you in this rock room oh [ __ ] oh
my god
wade why are you in there
what a nightmare nothing good mark what
was the other room that you discovered
is this okay
i don't know it's fine to walk into
wow oh it's zapping me i don't like that
and watch out these wow
every once in a while they kind of slap
you on the ass it's not
i hate i think the room that i opened is
probably the best one and then look how
terrible it is
i don't like that at all
huh
is it into the left i guess if we can
yeah
all right
here i'm already half health let me go
let me know let me know
and this is the
device
oh you're going for you're going for
look out behind
everything's dangerous i just exploded
into cold oh okay okay okay i believe in
mark oh god i believe in mark i believe
in mark oh don't run through the lasers
i didn't i didn't i didn't i didn't oh
man
oh oh there was a thing on the ground oh
my god
man we almost got damn time
we did almost have it maybe a pyramid
times five was optimistic because that
was a seven by seven room maybe maybe
maybe you never know
[Music]
we tried guys
we tried
[Music]
bye